very sad news from the science world
where physicist Stephen Hawking has died
at the age of 76 fifty years after he
was given only a couple of years to live
by doctors when he was diagnosed of
motor neurone disease lived in a
wheelchair spoke only through a voice
synthesizer for which he actually became
quite well-known popularizer of science
has written some tremendous science
books including one of my favorites a
brief history of time which has sold
more than 10 million copies but also
just on the news of Stephen Hawking's
passing shot to the top of the Amazon
bestseller list breaking news all over
the world
I was watching Argentinian news this
morning as I often do they were talking
about it a real giant in the world of
physics he was the first to put together
a sort of unified cosmology theory that
combined relativity and quantum
mechanics vizionary around black holes
discovered that black holes leak energy
and fade to nothing a phenomena that is
now named after him Hawking radiation
widely acclaimed in popular culture
appeared on a bunch of TV shows his life
was portrayed in the movie the theory of
everything did you see that one a couple
years old haven't seen that one
every book by him I highly recommend it
highly recommend it and the movie I've
not seen but have been told it is
excellent and there's this really
interesting Stephen Hawking story that
as a British subject people often wonder
why isn't he
Sir Stephen Hawking like how could
Stephen Hawking not have received
knighthood he actually turned it down
and there's two different stories and
maybe each is partially true one is
Stephen Hawking turned down British
knighthood because he doesn't like
titles the other story is he turned it
down as a sort of protest over the
British government's funding of science
or I guess better said the non funding
of science and Stephen Hawking's mind
very very interesting story and you know
I sort of never really know what else to
say in these situations but a giant in
the world of science we know a major
inspiration to Neil deGrasse Tyson who
now is carrying the
torch of Carl Sagan's Cosmos series
which is coming back to I believe it's
at least its second season if not beyond
that already I think the second season
so worldwide news worldwide news the
passing that Stephen Hawking certainly
saddening news but the fact that he was
able to live for 50 years in front of
ALS that's a remarkable achievement AB
science and his own abilities they don't
help no question about it and yeah when
somebody says you've got two years to
live and you live 50 that in an aside
from his a Hawking of radiation
discovery about the leaked energy of
black holes that in and of itself is
quite a life story and he will be missed
and I'm just a major major player in the
world of science